in 2020 apple announced that they were
going to ditch intel
and use their own chips and max this
decision effectively broke a 15-year
partnership
with intel and was a major surprise for
many who weren't closely following the
industry
given that apple's unit sales have more
or less stabilized apple has been able
to focus on diversifying their business
and bringing various aspects of their
business in-house and
it looks like their next target will be
even more surprising to many
as they are looking to potentially ditch
carriers and rival spacex
at the same time by now
i think we've all heard about starling
and what spacex is trying to accomplish
with starlink but if you haven't spacex
is basically launching thousands of
satellites into the sky
in order to provide fast and reliable
satellite internet to rural places
around the world this is a pretty clever
idea
as broadband providers either don't
support rural areas or then play
monopolistic pricing schemes while
offering terrible service
so this market is no doubt ready for
disruption and it's likely that starlink
will be extremely successful
amongst this population despite these
merits though
at the end of the day starlink is only
appealing to a niche demographic
the vast majority of people live in
large cities or the suburbs of large
cities
and broadband internet providers are
quite competitive within these areas
not to mention many of these areas have
fiber internet which starlings simply
can't compete with
at least not today there is a large
market that spacex is living on the
table though
which is a cell phone carrier market
fast and reliable satellite internet for
cell phones makes a lot of sense
i mean you don't move your house around
every day but you do move your phone
around
all over the place and even in the
largest cities around the world
cellular service is often dodgy in many
areas
so a satellite internet service for a
cell phone would be quite useful
especially if it increases reliability
satellite internet can of course
not compete against a max speed of 5g
but
here's the thing 5g is not even that
reliable at this point
and virtually no one even needs those
speeds on their phones
when it comes to cell phone service
reliability is generally much more
important than speed so
if satellite internet is able to
drastically improve reliability for a
similar price
it's likely that most will spring for
the satellite internet option
considering this massive opportunity why
didn't spacex target this market
well the answer is that they can't
satellite internet requires that the
receiving end has a dish
or specialized antennas designed to
receive signals from space
so spacex needs cooperation from cell
phone makers
in order to make satellite cell phone
service possible apple
on the other hand is the cell phone
maker so they're able to incorporate
satellite capability into iphones if
they want
and this seems to be exactly what they
are doing in december of 2019
bloomberg noticed that apple was hiring
dozens of engineers who specialize in
satellite and
antenna design apparently this secret
team is developing a method to beam
internet directly to iphones
ipads and macs from space this
technology
does already exist but satellite phones
are extremely large
and bulky so this team is likely
focusing on making this technology
compact
and seamless the bloomberg article also
points out that tim cook
is behind the effort so apple is likely
taking their project
extremely seriously at the time
bloomberg expected that if apple does
end up falling through with the project
we'll likely see a rollout in five years
meaning around 2024 or
2025. apple doesn't have launch
capability though
and i don't think they're going to
develop a rocket just to launch the
satellites
if they're looking for the most
economical way to launch a satellite
it'll probably be through spacex so
ironically
spacex would be helping apple set up
their own satellite internet business
apple doesn't have to necessarily use
their own satellites though
they could choose to simply rent out a
portion of the sterling constellation
or even partner with spacex to deploy
cell phone specific satellites
but given that apple can easily afford
to create and run their own
constellation
i don't think this scenario is as likely
that's all cool and all
but how popular would an apple cell
phone service even be
after all apple is notorious for using
kidneys as their preferred unit of
pricing
well while that is true for many of
their top level products
it's actually not true at all for the
services in fact apple is extremely
competitive when it comes to their
services
take apple music and spotify for
instance they both charge 9.99 a month
for their individual planes
14.99 a month for their family plans and
4.99 a month for their student plans
on top of this apple music has a more
extensive music library
and better integration with apple
devices for obvious reasons
this is the same case with icloud and
google drive as well
apple's cheapest tier offers 50
gigabytes for 99 cents per month
while google's cheapest tier offers 100
gigabytes for 1.99 per month
the price per gigabyte is the same but
apple actually has a cheaper entry price
both companies also offer 200 gigabytes
and one terabyte tiers which are priced
identically it should be noted though
that you can save 16 to 17
by going with google drive if you choose
your annual plans
nonetheless apple is quite competitive
with icloud as well
even though they don't really have to be
after all you can't automatically back
up your iphone to google
drive considering apple's history of
being competitive when it comes to
services
it's likely that they will be
competitive within the carrier market as
well
with that being said let's take a look
at just how profitable this venture
can be at the start of 2021 apple
announced that there were officially
over 1 billion iphones in active use
even if apple was able to capture just
10 percent of this market
they would be able to grow a subscriber
base of over 100 million customers
and honestly this wouldn't be that hard
for apple to accomplish
given their past success with
subscription services apple music for
instance had a total
of 72 million paid users at the end of
but that is nothing in comparison to
their total paid subscriber base
which stood at a mind-boggling 585
million customers and that was in
october of 2020
by now they're well above the 600
million customer mark
also don't forget that all of those
customers are buying optional services
you don't actually need apple music
or apple tv or icloud but virtually
everyone who buys an iphone needs a cell
phone service
and if satellite-based internet is more
reliable and apple is competitive in
terms of pricing
choosing apple wireless or whatever it's
called would be a no-brainer
i mean just think about it you'd be
getting better wireless service from
apple themselves for the same price
and that's not even considering the side
benefits apple will likely offer bundles
with their other services
which may even allow you to save money
by switching to apple wireless
it's also likely that many people will
switch simply to get away from legacy
carriers
who people seem to despise at t for
instance has a customer rating
of 1.2 stars with 91 of customers having
a one star experience similarly verizon
has a customer rating of 1.3 stores
with 86 percent of customers having a
one star experience
considering this i don't think it would
be too terribly difficult for a company
like apple to rack up 100 million
subscribers
around the world but how much money
would i even make
well the average american pays 70 per
month for the cell phone service
if apple's average subscriber pays the
same amount apple would pull in seven
billion dollars per month
or 84 billion per year from 100 million
subscribers
taking a look at apple's most recent
earnings report will see that their
gross margin on their services
is almost exactly 70 but that doesn't
account for operating expenses
we aren't exactly sure what proportion
of the operating expenses goes towards
their services
and what proportion goes towards their
products but if we say that their
operating expenses are proportional to
the revenue from each sector
we'll see that about 12 of the revenue
goes towards operating expenses
with six percent going towards research
and development and six percent going
towards selling
general and administrative expenses at
this point apple has 58
of the revenue remaining out of which 16
percent will go to taxes
leaving apple with about 49 percent of
the revenue as net profit
we won't estimate conservatively though
so we'll cut that down substantially and
call it in that margin of 30
with 84 billion dollars in revenue we're
left with a 25 billion
net profit annually to put that in
perspective
apple netted about 75 billion over the
past 12 months
meaning that apple wireless could easily
increase net income by 33 percent
currently apple's p e ratio is about 30
which means that the company is worth 30
times their annual income
the stock market is over extended right
now and that plus p e ratio will
continue to come down
as the business matures even further so
we'll assume that therapy ratio is down
to 20 by the time they rack up 100
million wireless subscribers
even at that rate apple wireless would
add 500 billion dollars on tapa's market
cap
where it gets really interesting though
is if apple is able to get a bigger
portion of the pie
which in my opinion is highly likely for
instance
if apple had 300 million wireless
subscribers they would pull in 252
billion dollars in revenue
and 75 billion net profit even with the
pe ratio of 15
apple wireless would add over 1.1
trillion dollars onto apple's already
monster market cap
at the end of the day given the
shortcomings of traditional cell phone
services
there is a massive untapped market for a
satellite-based cell phone service
that's done right apple is in a unique
position
where they can basically grow monopoly
centered around providing the service to
their billion iphone users
around the world by providing the
service apple will not only be able to
grow their bottom line by tens of
billions
and add hundreds of billions onto their
market cap but they can ditch the
reliance on carriers and rival starlink
at the same time did you guys realize
the massive gold mine that apple has
been sitting on
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video explained
the opportunity well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you